black is doing very well people really
like this show yeah it's a great show
it's a great show so I want to thank
everybody out there that's supporting
and watching the show for us you know
when the people when people first heard
the title there was some controversy
some people were bothered by the the
title blackish what was your take on it
was your family bothered at all they
weren't bothered by because you know as
long as I can support my mother's bingo
habit she signed with whatever I'm doing
so you know she's happy with it but you
know it's it's it's my life it's you
know my partner my producing partner
created the show Kenya Barris it's it's
a blend of his wife and children and my
wife and my children so it's the life
that we live being you know the the
flies in buttermilk the only
african-american families in our
neighborhood the only African American
families and at in private school my son
what not only was he the only chocolate
drop in his class he was the only he was
the only chocolate drop in his grade for
three years and so this is actually your
telling your story yeah yeah you're
entitled to tell this story I'm entitled
to tell the story and call it whatever
it is that I want to care I want to
because this is what I'm living yeah
you're you talked about you mentioned
your mom your I've heard your mom as a
character that yes ed you're supporting
her bingo habit yeah what and I think
you've talked about your mom before she
is she's always been a little unusual
always been a little left of center
growing up and in my house you know most
people get sick their mother gives them
robitussin
you know aspirin we got cuts and bruises
my mother would give us vagisil what yes
vagisil we've had your cell yes yes you
supposed to put like neosporin or right
yeah that's what we said and she said if
it's good enough for my it's good enough
for you
[Laughter]
she would say that so would it work it
did yeah but but I always wondered why
my mother had so much is your mom gonna
be happy that you're talking about this
my mom is always as long as I could
support her bingo have a problem with
what I say yeah see how can she be mad
at the truth Conan no it's the truth
that I have found my mom when I tell the
truth is unhappy that's the difference
at all
but yes my mother will sit upon his
couch and tell you everything that I
just told you is and say it's exactly
true yeah you got to bring your mom next
time next next time I will it's gonna be
Conan after dark if I bring
would you please bring your mom that'll
be really seriously there'll be a really
fun mama you got it you got an invite
from Kohn and I'm bringing you two next
time I'm here that's gonna be great
that's gonna be great television
[Applause]
all right well blackish again
congratulations black-ish Aires is very
smart very funny blackish airs Wednesday
nights at 9:30 on ABC it's doing really
well Anthony Anderson thanks so much I
know you're busy no progress to your mom
thank you bye
you